well we know misinformation and
conspiracy theories are spreading faster
than ever before largely online but
quantifying the damage they do is not
easy now a group of academics has
attempted to add up the impact of
misinformation about covid-19 in Canada
the Council of Canadian academies
estimates misinformation contributed to
the vaccine hesitancy of more than 2
million Canadians during a nine-month
period in 2021 it estimates that
hesitancy led to at least 2 800 deaths
along with an estimated 300 million
dollars in medical costs it says
misinformation also led to deep
divisions within Society even within
families divisions that continue today
and as Heather York's West explains
there is no vaccine for that
I want to cry
it makes me so sad
um that so many people could have been
saved for Trudy Ballard the findings of
a new study by the Council of Canadian
academies feels so personal because they
are in October 2021 Trudy Ballard lost
her dad he died of covet 19. there's so
much misinformation being put out there
and unfortunately he believed a lot of
that Ballard believes misinformation
prevented her dad from getting the covid
vaccine researchers say he was far from
alone using a mathematical model a panel
of experts have tried to measure the
cost of covid misinformation in both
dollars and lives what would things have
been like had all those people who died
kobit was a hoax gotten vaccinated as
soon as they were eligible had that
happened the models suggest that within
a nine-month period of 2021 there would
have been 198 000 fewer covid-19 cases
13 000 fewer people in hospital and 3
500 fewer patients in ICU it wasn't just
anti-vaccine and conspiracy theory in
the 5G chip theory that was that was
ripping through our hospital it was the
lack in of faith in healthcare
professionals and expertise that was
killing us and it's that distrust and
the anger that followed that's perhaps
more difficult to quantify and even
harder to fix we were the victims of
death threats um to this day I have
certain distant family members who
accuse me daily of being a mass murderer
from vaccination so what's the solution
the CCA report says there's a lot of
work to be done from holding social
media companies more accountable to
ensuring accurate information is
communicated more effectively of course
nothing can be done to give Trudy time
back with her dad she just hopes
something can be learned from his death
Heather York's West Global News Calgary